s
citoyens ont entraîné
d'importantes manifestations
autorités. Lise Villeneuve.
(cris)
- "Non à la guerre!" moment momt
de son arrestation
lors d'utation
à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Ils sont plus de 1300 à avoir
rassemblements qui ont suivi
l'annonce de la mobilisationréus
sur un potentiel militaire
de 25 millions de personnes.
"Mon petit ami a reçu une note
de l'intendance militaire po
être mobilisé, dit cette femme,
je suis ici pour manifester
à sa place."
"Nous sommes venus pour protéger
que le président veut entraîner
dans cette guerre brutale",
dit cet étudiant.
On apprend aujourd'hui
que plusieurs des manifestants
arrêtés se sont vus imposer
un ordre de conscr
L'annonce de la mobilisation a
les billets d'avion aller-simple
pour n'importe quelle
destination.
Une information niée par Moscou.
"C'est complètement exagéré,
dit le porte-parole du Kremlin,
il n'y a pas de cohue
c'est de la "fake news"."
Des centaines de voitures
faisaient pourtant la file
pendant des heures en pleine
nuit à la frontière
En direction de la Finlande
aussi, le traffic s'est
intensifié pendant la nuit.
Ceux qui ont pu mettre la m
sur un billet d'avion, dont
prix ont explosé depuis hier,
sont heureux d'avoir
pu quitter la Russis inquiet,
dit ce passager en provenance
de Moscoensais
jamais qu'on se rendrait
à la mobilisation."
"La gueroce,
dit cet homme, qui vient
d'atterrir à Belgrade,
L'Union L'Union L'Union L'Unior
que ses membres s'accordentsur e
à cet afflux de migrants russes,
alors que l'Allemagne a déjà
annoncé être prête à accueillir.
Ici Lise Villeneuve
Radio-Canada, Mon